[Music]
in the spot where the twin towers once
stood there is now a calmness a piece in
the heart of manhattan
a void that will never be filled a place
for private moments of reflection
to remember a day 20 years ago when
their lives changed
when the world changed
[Music]
nearly 3 000 people died
in new york
at the pentagon in washington
and in the pennsylvania countryside the
fourth plane brought down by passengers
and crew it was heading for the
of all the sons and daughters
husbands and wives grandparents and
friends
each of their names is etched here
over the coming hours relatives and
survivors will share their stories of
loss and of healing
they'll be joined at the ceremony by the
president his secretary of state
speaking today for the administration
maybe more than any other event in our
lifetimes
911 shape the trajectory of our country
and how we engage in the world
it was a trajectory which began here at
ground zero with a president reflecting
the mood of a traumatized nation
consumed by
who knock these revenge
down
will hear all of us soon
[Applause]
a president's vow 20 years ago was
another president's burden just a few
weeks ago with the chaotic exit from
afghanistan and the vacuum it left
the legacy of 9 11 has been profound and
it endures 20 years has perhaps allowed
individuals time to begin to heal but
collectively for america and beyond it
has prompted new and troubling questions
if bin laden
was still around how do you think he
would
judge the past 20 years i think the sad
truth of the matter is that if bin laden
were alive today he'd be a happy man
firstly the enterprise that he commenced
over three decades ago
has withstood
what really is the technologically most
advanced military in the history of
mankind and survived there are now four
times as many salafi-jihadi groups in
other words groups that adhere to bin
laden's ideology
today than there were on 9 11.
back at ground zero two young
firefighters too young to remember 9 11
but here to remember it still i think
that uh
we'll leave here today
i think more motivated
be more humble i guess is a better word
so
we're just
so thankful i'm grateful as well
for new york for america and well beyond
this will be a painful reflection of
such an extraordinary moment mark stone
sky news at ground zero